so the reason why we're here today is
because it's been six days
and we don't want the public to forget
about amari
we want to keep his name out there we
want to keep his face out there
we're asking that if anyone could help
us get a billboard
for amari that would be useful if
someone could help us with a website
where the public could call in
and give any type of tips that they have
for amari
that would be useful we don't want him
to be another story
we want people to remember amari and
help us bring him home
safely
you've been updated at all on the police
investigation what's the latest any new
information
it's an active investigation so there's
only so much that the police can tell us
we do know that they're using all their
resources to help us find omari
but we still don't have any leads which
is why we're continuing to come out
and ask for people to continue to look
for amari and help us find him
we need the public's help
also the family has been out surfing
going door to door is that right can you
describe for us
what your efforts have been yes we've
been staying in this area mostly
there are other search teams out and
about in the city looking
but basically what we're doing is just
trying to jog people's memory get his
picture out there
keep him in everyone's mind and remind
everyone it's six days
and they're still a two-year-old and we
have no idea where he is
i have a question for margarita was
there an amber alert refuted in this
case and if so why not
so the amber alert nevada criteria
is a child has to be
taken with a vehicle description and
there is no vehicle description
we also don't have a suspect description
so those are two criterias for the amber
alert nevada
they are different in every state but
this is unfortunately what nevada's
criteria
is but what has been issued and what was
activated is a missing
endangered child alert which is what
metro has activated and also our agency
so if you're watching this and you
shared that flyer thank you because you
made the difference
there have been tips that have come in
but unfortunately we don't have that
information that goes directly to law
enforcement
and we just need more people to just
come out and i know you've been probably
out here we've had
hundreds of volunteers come and help
share flyers but we can't stop we're not
going to stop until he's found
do you feel confident that amari's not
with anyone on the paternal side of the
family do you know everyone in your
family right the person said that they
were on the paternal side
is there any possibility that someone on
your side of the family has them or
you've ruled that out
there's no possibility that anyone on
our side of the family has him
and that's why we're out here to try to
figure out who does have him
someone has to have seen something have
you been in contact with the mother side
of the family are they helping and i
know
yesterday he said not pointing fingers
or any of that but
what's their involvement and are they
trying to help too we have not been in
contact with the mother's side of the
family
we are open to working with her we want
her to know that we want to help her
find amari
like i mentioned before we're moms i
can't imagine what it's like to not have
your son at home for six days in a row
and have no idea where he is
so we want to help her find her son
what is your reaction to knowing that
she's not out here with you guys trying
to help
i don't know i honestly don't know and i
don't want to speculate because i don't
want her to feel like
we're against her but we're here to help
her
we want to help her find her
any managers songs they do you know if
the video was working at the time the
camera system
that's the part of the investigation
that the police is conducting right now
have you talked with any neighbors who
knew amari
we've talked to neighbors and
i mean we're not we're just not getting
out any leads on where he could be
and that's why you know we it feels like
we've exhausted what we could do
here for now and that's why we want to
reach out to people everywhere
we do want everyone in the country to
know
because it's been six days and he could
be anywhere
we've only seen those stories on
facebook
we don't know for sure and like i said
before it's an open investigation
there's only so much that they will tell
us right now
so right now we feel like all of that is
speculation until the police come to us
and say
that that's a fact
what's next for you guys today are you
going to continue handing out flyers
what would you like to be done
we're going to continue to hand out
flyers in different parts of the city
um but like i said we need we need more
we need more resources yeah and
what's our plea today as well is to just
let the public know that you can call
nevada child seekers
our phone number 702-458-7009
i will drive to you and i will give you
flyers if you want to hand them out in
param
or any part of the city if you are out
of state and you want to
share and be a part of this i will mail
you flyers there is nothing we won't do
to help bring them home
right what we want is for people
to connect this to them think about a
two-year-old that you know
think about what a two-year-old can do
how far can a two-year-old go
how well can a two-year-old communicate
and that's why we're
we're devastated if anyone has had a
child or has been around a two-year-old
you know how defenseless they are
at this age and that's why we need help
we need resources we need to get
omaree's name out there
we don't want people to forget about him
the same way they wouldn't forget about
the two-year-old at their house
so just think about how you would feel
if this was your two-year-old and you
hadn't seen him in six days
and no one knew where he could possibly
be for six days
the best he can the best he can yeah he
there's not much that he feels
defenseless like there's not
much that he can do to bring his son
home and he also has no idea where his
son is
he has other children too that he's
trying to be strong for
but what can you do in this situation
like
there's no handbook for how to feel or
how to handle this
[Music]
as far as we know since amari has gone
missing now
uh living arrangements did they go back
and forth to the shared custody could
you describe it
his mother had full custody of amari his
mother had sold custody of amari
they were beginning to try to
communicate and
you know get a better relationship going
between the two but
his mother had full custody
there is a reward thirty thousand
dollars for anyone that can bring amari
home safely there's a lot of billboards
around las vegas
please help us please help us it's
the longer time goes on the less likely
we're going to find something
walking around and knocking on doors
there's so many people that come and go
from las vegas
that it's it feels like it's so heavy on
us
how long it's been and how much
we just anything helps any resources
that they can put for
if you know somebody who can either put
his flyer in print or on a billboard or
you know um this billboard right here
would be
fantastic um once again we're just a
family begging for help
and um
we've covered some of this trip um we
plan on doing
more today and like you said different
areas throughout las vegas
um we're not going to stop anywhere we
can look anywhere we can go we will be
doing
and if you're out there and you see
someone hand you a flyer of amari please
take it
please take it because you don't know
what you may have some information
and unknowingly that can solve this that
can solve it and bring them home
so we initially started of course with
metro the search
right here um in front of the emerald
suites i know they've done all of their
investigation
in this area interviewed people i know
they're still doing it
um but as a team we're gonna start doing
pockets of the city from like summerland
you know to the strip to anthem
and if you're in those areas and you
want to help contact our office i'll
give you flyers
we just need more people like i said
sharing his story
and sharing our plea to bring him home
have you guys talked with the boyfriend
we had no contact with him
no no contact with any of them
how do you their relationship are you
guys familiar with anything about their
relationship i mean
how long are they dating no no
we don't know anything about taylor or
her boyfriend
like we have very minimal details and
that's why we're trying not to
discuss it too much because we don't
want to speculate we don't want to put
things out there that aren't true
and we don't want her to feel like she
can't come to us if she needs
fly or is there help place you can get
more videos or
any video or do you have any available
we've been
sending pictures to the different news
outlets that reached out to us
um but that's about it
we can't confirm or deny we don't know
we just want to thank everyone that has
come out we would like to thank all the
news outlets
when we reached out you guys responded
so quickly
to help us and we do appreciate
everyone's help
and we want people to continue to look
and
continue to put his name out there until
he comes home
thank you